welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition in this episode
were breaking down the second entry of
Picard our mission is to boldly go where
no one has gone before
and give our thoughts on the follow-up
and what could be happening in the
future
throughout this video we'll be
discussing the ins and outs of the
second episodes plot it's Easter eggs
and what we thought of it as a whole
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to catch the
show yet and don't want to know what
happens then I highly suggest that he
turn off now make sure you subscribe to
the channel for daily breakdowns like
this and a weekly recap of Picard the
day that is without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for quick in
this video now let's get into our
breakdown of Picard episode 2 okay so
just a quick recap of the first episode
we joined John Luke Picard on his French
vineyard where he was haunted by visions
of data data seemingly died decades
prior and this has followed the
character throughout his elder yes after
a massive attack on Mars synthetics have
been outlawed and there is a lot of
prejudice towards them in the galaxy we
discovered that data had a daughter
named osh and she was being hunted by
assassins though she went to picard for
help these proved too much and she was
killed
however the lineage of data is not lost
forever then we learned that dodge had a
twin sister who was working on a big
ball cube in space episode two picks up
14 years ago on Mars in 2385
amidst the aforementioned synthetic
uprising we know that the androids that
caused the uprising came from the
daystrom Institute and that no one has
been able to replicate the complexities
of datas personality dr. Bruce Maddox
who was a key player in defining whether
he was a person or not failed to
accomplish this with the characters
brother b4 anyway on Mars it's happy
first contact day but his contact day is
celebrated on the 5th of April and it
marks the time that the humans first
made their contact with the Vulcans in
2063 the celebration first made its
appearance in Star Trek Voyager and
since then it's become a minor holiday
because of this most of the staff at the
Mars station are off work and the group
that we see are operating with a
skeleton crew
the primary Android we follow is f8 like
fate get it and this kind of points out
the fact that the humans were always
destined to clash with the robots how
many times must we watch The Matrix and
terminator before we learned at the
station we see a replicator that creates
meals these are primarily used to
synthesize food and it's inclusion here
showcases just how much synthetics are
needed in modern-day Stockley life all
of a sudden f8 I switch almost as if he
was uploaded with a program and he goes
wild unleashing the devastating attack
was it just was it just me or did these
guys remind you of the working joes from
alien isolation anyway
containment fails and the planet pretty
much gets wiped out with f8 destroying
himself so that he cannot be studied did
I just assume the gender of an Android
no wonder they hate us back in the
present we pick up at Chateau Picard and
we learned that dodge is being
completely erased from any camera
footage Picard's homies talk about the
shock rush which is a talia myth that is
basically the boogeyman of the
federation these secret police are a big
part of Romulan mythology and it's
rumored that these undead soldiers got
secrets so crazy that learning one would
break a person's mind
Adarsh is flat they tried to use Romulan
technology to recreate the attack on her
from the assassins that we saw in the
first episode however the vastus eeen of
anti leptons to scrub everything from
any possible surveillance the Jaguar
sharply the Germans in World War 2 I
can't say what they are because of
YouTube monetization and they completely
hate all forms of synthetic life and
wish to wipe it all from the galaxy this
explains well it's pretty much no
presence of androids in Romulan culture
Picard is able to track them though due
to their need to make the scene look
like it hasn't been surgically removed
because of dodges similarity to a sister
due to their replication they discovered
that soul-g may have seemed to be dodgy
at one point and through this they are
able to trace her the investigation
really picks up the pace of the show and
for people who were complaining last
week that it was a bit slow a definitely
thing that they'll be swept up here as
it does a phenomenal job of getting you
on board speaking of on board we joined
so g1 small onboard the Borg cube that
has been
in the vastness of space we learn that
this is in fact an artifact and that it
hasn't been built but rather restored
and once it's back in tip-top shape we
can get it going and get brexit done a
wealth of races inhabit the craft
including Romulans humans and of course
the Android Sochi the fact that so DS
boyfriend who is Romulan is getting so
close to the Borg shows that the
previous statement on the species hate
of synthetics may no longer be true we
do know from last week that there was an
event known as the Romulan supernova in
which the planet was destroyed because I
wanted to rescue those who were stuck
there like a Dunkirk in space and he
wished to have help from Starfleet
however due to the attack on Mars their
attentions lay elsewhere and thus Picard
couldn't help those he so desperately
wanted to the Romulans still keep their
secrets closely guarded and Shoji has
difficulty finding out what's going on
from him the theme of the episode is
very much secrets and keeping things
hidden and this is exemplified here we
do kind of get the feeling that
everything is being kept under the
surface and this is showcased in
Picard's diagnosis in the episode we are
introduced to more it's been a you know
an old friend of the cod that served
with him on the USS stargazer the two go
way back but he has some bad news for
Picard it turns out that though he's in
brilliant shape on the surface Picard is
actually suffering from aromatic
syndrome in Star Trek terms this is an
Alzheimer's like condition that causes
him to have hallucinations and blanks in
his memory it's labeled as being a death
sentence for the character Picard needs
to go into Stella and Maurice gives him
a clean bill of health which will allow
him to travel and get to the bottom of
the mystery we see Picard arrive in San
Fran and it looks like one of the alien
crew members from the Borg cube could be
seen here too we don't offer definite
but they kind of linger on her for a bit
long so might not be here we really
don't know but there is talk in the
episode of moles being in Starfleet and
I do think this is kind of what's going
on here or maybe it's just they needed
someone on set quickly and she'd already
had her makeup done
seemed her gender again I'm sorry don't
test like the video we see holograms of
the enterprise from over the years and
bokar divulges to an admiral that Bruce
Maddox has been trying to build a
synthetic organic life-form if you
checked out my last video you'll know
that we discussed how in the episode
measure of a man that Maddox wished to
take data and study him as he did not
view him as a person this conversation
hints at the overall conspiracy as a
whole and it does say that he may be
working with the Romulans and the data
could also be out there in the galaxy
somewhere this is kind of cleared up
towards the end but I'll get into that
theory later in the video
now what this conversation does is that
it adds a lot of weight to our theory
that data will be resurrected and his
consciousness will be uploaded into his
brother before though this failed in the
films I do personally think that it will
be put in place here and this will be a
big way to bring the character back the
actor is clearly on board as he's
popping up in dreams so yeah that's my
theory for the moment
Picard butts heads with the Admiral who
pretty much refuses him a crew after his
outbursts on TV from the last episode in
which he criticized Starfleet we're here
later in the episode that this is
Admiral Clancy and it could be that this
is a continuation of ensign can see from
the next generation we don't get it
confirmed but we do learn that they do
know each other so I kind of connected
the dots on that but God seems to be
going off the deep end and it reminds us
of how complex a character that this
depiction is going with you kind of get
the feeling that Picard can't really be
trusted especially in light of his
diagnosis and I'm so glad they're taking
a mature look at the character rather
than just being like everyone loves him
you can do what he want his request is
denied and returns home to feed aboard
the Borg cube we see that Sochi is a
pretty low ranking worker and this is
why her relationship with norik a
high-ranking official must be kept
secret the Romulans are clearly running
the show here and it is sort of depict
how things could work going forward
there is a worry that the Borg may we
stabilize and run riot but overall it
becomes clear that most of the people
coming to the cube are hoping for
sanctuary and to study things it's not
clear exactly what is going on but I
just want to bring up a theory that I
saw on my last video
that I think states how the ball maybe I
did say that I thought they'd become the
villains of the season but this comment
changed my mind massively the comment
comes from Kirk 0:01 and says I really
really doubt the Borg or the villain of
this series I think they play a role of
oppressed peoples here previous trailers
showed de Bourgh go fight drones kept in
internment camps Patrick Stewart was
motivated to do the show in response to
a brexit / Trump world which has had a
strong emotional impact on him
Federation / Romulan views of the synth
and the Borges in the series appeared to
be analogies to Western societies
interaction with Muslims and the Middle
East
they kind of say that the synthetic amaz
sort of echoes back to 9/11 I recall
reading 7 of 9 has been fighting to help
former drones that remained imprisoned
by the Federation and Romulans I suspect
that the seasons arc will revolve around
three interrelated parts one finding the
truth about Dodge / solji - liberating
imprisoned former drones who have been
unjustly held for years without trial
under the argument that they are too
dangerous to be freed even if they're no
longer part of the collective and three
discovering who has been manipulating me
events are officially triggering a
supernova to destroy Romulus executing a
rogue synth attack to give the
Federation justification for denying in
900 million Romulans refugee relocation
assistance and triggering the ban on
creation of artificial life so yeah I
just thought I'd add that in as it
definitely makes sense I was gonna just
steal that theory and say it's mine but
sometimes I can't be the good guy we see
the Box being harvested in the episode
and clearly they're being cultivated for
something rather than being the enemy
force throughout so G clearly feels
sympathetic towards them and yeah I
think it's clear that going one way with
the show dr. Agnes arrives at the
vineyard with some materials from
maddux's study and we learned that
Maddox probably created dodge and Sochi
to look like the painting because it's
what they are left behind not the other
way around it was theorized that he may
have created them then made the painting
but this clears it up it's revealed that
dodge was enrolled at de strim
but her credentials were completely
fictional so as we guess last week her
memories were likely implants she was
likely created by
three years prior to the show and thus
her mother could also be a hologram as
we theorized McCord seems like a lost
soul staring into the Stars and he puts
his badge back on and sends a message
out into the cosmos staff we aren't
happy though and we see a Vulcan
commander talking about how they hoped
he was mothballed on a desk sits a
replica of the Care Shara from the
enterprise which contains the teachings
of Zurich I didn't spot this someone on
reddit did I should have stole that well
yeah I'm giving credit this episode
Picard goes to get a ship and we join
lieutenant Rizzo who's been assigned to
track him it's mentioned that she's
messed up a couple of things at
Starfleet however as we see in the
finale this was clearly intentional as
she's likely a double agent working with
the Romulans
she has been disguised as entire time
and has a secret agenda oh my god did I
just assume her agenda make sure you
subscribe the channel but top quality
jokes like that every week
they've been manipulating the inner
workings of Starfleet and this is likely
how they've remained undetected we
learned that they are keeping a close
eye on Sochi to find a location of a
nest of synthetics though dodge has been
destroyed there is clearly more of it
elk out there and who knows there may
even be a replica of data personally I
believe that the nest is referring to
dr. Maddux's lab in the galaxy somewhere
they'll be attempting to track this down
to wipe out the synthetics and organics
in one fell swoop it ends the episode on
a big cliffhanger and next time it looks
like Picard will be getting a ship
whilst the net closes in on Sochi it's
really ramping up and I had a lot of fun
with this entry as I did the last so far
Picard has been a blast and I can't wait
to see what happens next
now obviously let me know your thoughts
on the episode in the comments below and
if you enjoyed the video then please
give it a thumbs up and make sure you
check out a breakdown from last week if
you missed it have you already checked
it out then please watch our breakdown
of the new info that we have on the
Batman which goes over the villains that
are gonna be appearing in the movie if
you want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below you get
access to content early and can suggest
video topics and breakdowns we massively
appreciate it and it goes a long way to
helping videos like this get made and if
you want to come chat to us after the
show either follow us at Definition YT
or click the discord link in description
below every month we give away free
movies to people who are subscribed to
the channel and this month he can win
dr. sleep and all you have to do is
comment on a video and make sure you sub
with notifications on the more videos
you comment on the more you have a
chance of winning so make sure you get
involved but when it's gonna be chosen
at random on the 15th of February it's
the best of luck that everyone who takes
part this is the channel for people who
are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]